[Music]
Intel's Arc a750 might give the company
a fighting chance or at least the
beginnings of one in the graphics Market
the a770 it just couldn't overcome the
driver issues or counterbalance them
sufficiently given the price it had but
the a750 is generally within six to
eight percent of an a770 and it's priced
at 290 dollars as opposed to 350 for the
16 gigabyte 770. so already the value
looks much better against Intel's own
higher end card this isn't new though
we've seen this in the past like with
the RX 470 versus the RX 480 from AMD
for example and so today we're looking
at the 750 which is poised for a better
fight at 290 dollars it still has all
the same driver issues as the 770 of
course but they might be a little bit
easier to look past depending on what
type of user you are before that this
video is brought to you by be quiet and
there's silent wins for fans the silent
wins four vans Market themselves as
being useful on radiators Tower coolers
and cases alike the fans have a six-pole
motor and use a fluid Dynamic bearing
which helps with the noise profile and
with longevity the fans use
anti-vibration mounts for reduced noise
transfer to the case and have a rated
lifespan of 300 000 hours learn more at
the link in the description below so for
the driver discussion and what these
cards are we've already talked about all
that we'll link both of those videos
below but the drivers in the 770 review
it's all the same problems with the 750
we're not going to go over the whole
thing again the biggest problem that
Intel has right now is these cards are
still lacking some very basic features
and the reason they're lacking features
because even within the same team Intel
is scattered and not really focusing on
the right thing they're focused on
stuffing all this bloated into
their drivers rather than trying to get
the basics working like being able to
control the fans for example or being
able to use the user interface without
becoming infuriated but they'll
hopefully get there and we're still
excited about the fact that now when we
go through GPU benchmarking we've got
three different brand names that that
show up on a chart the first time we
typed in Intel at the front of a video
card to go into a GPU Benchmark chart
was actually a pretty exciting time so
hopefully Intel can pull through but the
drivers will leave the discussion to the
Past videos they're still not there that
said with the right value combination it
might start to make sense for a user who
I really just wants to buy it almost as
like a toy like something to mess around
with uh that can hopefully handle the
games you play reasonably well it's
useful for things like certain coding
aspects as well we're not looking at
that stuff today but from a gaming
perspective uh perhaps in the Enthusiast
tanker Market there's still space for
this even though it doesn't quite fit
the mainstream because it would be too
frustrating to use and we just can't
recommend it there but get into this
thing so for the differences the a750
runs 28 XE cores as opposed to the a770
which is at 32. so the 750 is at most of
a 770 in terms of what the GPU contains
for Shader cores it's at 4096 Honda 770
and it's at 35.84 on the 750. memory has
us at 8 gigabytes here which is plenty
for this class of card and it's a
256-bit boss on both the 770 and the 750
also the 750 is still pcie gen 4x16 so
you've got all your land and it's also a
225 watt TDP just like the 770. for a
quick reference we showed this in the
last review as well we have a price
table we just looked up some cards we
took three of the cheapest ones averaged
some really simple stuff we didn't do
anything Advanced or special here and
did that before our review so we kind of
frame what competes with what when going
into the 750 and 770s okay enough of all
that uh this one is genuinely much more
interesting from like a benchmarking and
game standpoint than the 770 because
that value is so much stronger so let's
get straight into it and start with some
benchmarks well it's got thermals power
uh the fan behavior and gaming here's
the thermal chart for the a770 and the
a750 this time and we're going to
repopulate it with the a770 First with
that one we observed the 7 72 Degree
Target temperature for the GPU with the
memory running about 80 degrees thermals
ramped to a steady state temperature at
about 250 seconds so relatively slow due
to the rapid fan ramp here Intel could
burn some more time on fan increase in
RPM to try and reduce how audible the
uptick in speed is and this comes down
to the fan curve that set in V bios
alongside the temperature Target memory
thermals ran at about 78 degrees which
is completely reasonable for modern gtr6
memory packages so no problems there the
cooler at least appears to be adequate
as for how the fan responds to these
conditions it ramps to about 1600 RPM to
hold the target temperature of 70
degrees just like the a770 except the
fan can spin about 100 to 200 RPM slower
while holding the same temperature we
already tested noise levels in the a770
review so you can check that for more
detail it's the same set of fans so the
noise is the same power testing is up
now and this one the Intel r a750 pulled
234 Watts when under a full load that
has it alongside the RX 6800 so the a750
is far less power efficient here for
what you're getting and it's also about
the same as the 3070. once again Intel
has a ways to go for power efficiency
even on tsmc's node the rx6600 is
another example of this at 137 Watts the
6600 didn't regularly outperform the
a750 in benchmarking but it didn't
enough cases to embarrass it at that
power difference we'll start the gaming
benchmarks with Total War Warhammer 3 at
1080p with a custom set of high graphic
settings where our standard deviation
for average FPS is only 0.3 FPS this is
an extremely precise test in our suite
the rk750 tested at 83 FPS average
beaten by the a770 by about 8 percent at
90 FPS average so that 7 or so FPS that
is what costs you the extra 50 or 60
bucks like 20 more expensive over to get
to the a770 and that makes the a750 look
good value-wise especially considering
intel only sent out the 16 gigabyte 770s
which are more expensive moving to
comparisons versus Nvidia the a750
outperforms the RTX 3050 by 33 and the
3050 cost four percent more than the
750. it's clear why Intel chose to make
comparisons to Nvidia when boasting
about price to Performance because
that's where it makes Arc look the best
forgetting about AMD entirely does Intel
some favors here the 750 performed 14
better than the old RTX 2060 which is
actually still available for about 248
dollars new making the a750 17 more
expensive for that 14 gain the 2060
still somehow remains relevant as even a
new purchase in 2022 compared to the RX
6600 XT at 323 bucks they sometimes the
leads by 3.6 percent and it leads the
248.6600
60 by 23 so in this game the a750 looks
good for Value moving to 1440p the Intel
a750 came up has 57 FPS average just
behind the a770 which scored about eight
percent higher the a750 outdid the RTX
3050 by a large 41 margin clearly
establishing itself has a better value
than nvidia's cheapest RTX card as for
the RX 6600 Intel's a750 runs a 39
higher average FPS while costing 40 to
50 dollars more additionally the a750
beat the RTX 2060 by 20 and the RX 6600
XT by 16 the Intel a750 pulls ahead and
1440p proportional to its 1080p Rank and
that is due to its advantages and higher
resolutions AMD as a reminder has sort
of the opposite it has an advantage at
1080p so that's why these stack UPS
really widen the gap between these two
Brands as resolution grows next up is
Rainbow Six Siege at 1080p where the
Intel Alchemist GPU is set at the bottom
of the chart even below the old RX 580
and GTX 1070 it's just embarrassing we
confirmed these numbers with Intel and
we also ran the test multiple times the
arc cards would do better with Vulcan
but suffer with dx11 in some games and
this is one of them the a750s poor
performance here is really brought to
light by the RTX 3050 which is 97 ahead
in average FPS the a750 was just leading
the 3050 in the last test so to swing
this hard of a loss is impressive and it
speaks to the issues with a new vendor
where it's just not that predictable the
RTX 2060 leads the a750 by 122 percent
with the 6600 XT leading by a comically
wide gap of 186 percent Advantage so at
this point it's just an Intel Arc
problem the a750 at 120 FPS is led by
the a770 by only five percent but
everything else the Gap is much wider
than it should be here is the frame time
chart as a reminder lower better but
more consistent is best the problem is
Apparent at first glance here from
frames 0 to 100 the frame times are
between 14 and 16 milliseconds for Intel
and then they immediately drop down to
about eight milliseconds slowly they
climb again and then sharply drop again
we see another huge increase in frame
times from frame 1950 to 2050 and again
near the end of the chart now oddly Visa
actually still consistent in the sense
that any cluster of frames is pretty
close together and that's good there are
only occasional massive changes but one
of those every now and then we change
scenes or transition in an environment
that's okay the RX 580 though gives us
the contrast where it maintains a low
frame timeline across the entirety of
the test both cards are fairly
consistent in terms of the every few
seconds they're clustered close to each
other but the 580 is consistent
throughout the entirety of The Benchmark
Intel Arc has issues with just certain
scenes threatless tasks even with
Intel's 1440p and 4K advantages it can't
overcome the basic problem of just not
running the X11 well in this game the
a750 ends up at 99 FPS average at 1440
which sounds fine except the 580 has the
same frame rate and significantly better
lows so for this one Intel has managed
to make something that performs the same
as a 200 to 250 card from 2017 which
itself is a refresh of a card from 2016.
we might as well look at 4K before
moving away from this game but for now
we can Mark Rainbow Six as functionally
broken on Arc at 4K the 750 ran at 66.6
FPS average the number of the Beast
except the Beast is actually Intel's
drivers the 66.6 FPS result had about
the same as the RX 6600 and that amount
of sixes is just dangerous for YouTube's
Auto captioning and might get us
demonetized so we're gonna move on F1
2022 is one of the easiest Graphics
loads we test but it still manages to be
GPU Bound in most scenarios it's also
running the X12 so we can give Arc a
safe haven from the scars left on it by
Rainbow Six the a750 ran at 100 FPS
average leading the 300 RTX 3050 by
about eight percent it's not a huge lead
but under normal circumstances that'd be
enough to consider the 290 a750 instead
unfortunately for Intel there are wider
issues that require a much bigger
advantage to overcome the performance
and consistency games a game for some
other options the RTX 2060 leads the
a750 marginally but not noticeably and
the a770 does about the same with only a
6 FPS jump the RX 6600 would be the next
major step up it's about 20 FPS more or
so and the pricing has Arc cost in forty
dollars more so it's looking good for
the 66. at 1440p scaling shifts the a750
ahead of the 2060 now leading by a
slight but measurable six percent the
lead over the 3050 gross to 19 and
that's up from eight percent at 1080p
it's a big jump starting to become a
noticeable Advantage for Intel and those
aren't bad here either it's managing to
maintain frame time consistency while
also pulling ahead and performance
Advantage Let's See How Far That that
scaling will carry the card at 4K the
a750 now pulls ahead of the RTX 3050 by
32 percent so it's gone from 8 to 19 to
32 percent that's some wild scaling and
not something we've traditionally seen
we know Nvidia did better towards the 4K
side and AMD did better at 1080p but
we've never seen the differences jump
This Much from one resolution to the
next even the a770 broke rank here it
pulled ahead by 17 versus the a750 which
is uncharacteristic this illustrates to
us that the hardware differences in the
a770 are becoming more relevant to its
hierarchical rank even against a card
with the same architecture when the load
is sufficient at 4K but as for the a750
the card remains mostly playable you'd
just be best off dropping the settings
or resolution to get a solid 60 FPS
Final Fantasy 14 is up now tested using
dx11 and running on maximum settings
dx11 is one of the weaker cases for Arc
as we've seen but it does surprisingly
well on Final Fantasy and that scales
rapidly as the rest resolution increases
the a750 ran at 164 FPS average here
which had it functionally the same as
the a770s 173 FPS average the 770 only
has a lead of 5.4 percent which again
isn't worth the 21 price increase so the
a770 almost really doesn't need to exist
for this initial launch it would just be
better for Intel's reputation but they
needed multiple products so compared to
the rx6600 the a750 leads it by about
five percent with a slight reduction in
lead from the RTX 3060 while being
significantly cheaper the RX 6600xde
holds an 11 lead here 1440p gets more
interesting where we previously saw an
advantage of about five percent over the
RX 6600 the a750 now leads by a massive
28 percent Intel scaling is coming into
play the car jumps ahead of the 6600 XT
as well Landing only behind the RTX 3070
the RX 6700 T and things above that as
for the a770 that's almost linear in
scaling predictably because it's the
same architecture and it lands again at
about five percent ahead at 4K the a750
ran at 52 FPS average keeping about the
same distance between it and the a770
from previous tests the card is playable
whereas the rx6600 has dropped into
territory where you'd be better off
reducing the resolution the lead of the
a750 over the 6600 is now 42 percent so
it climbed from five percent to 28 to 42
percent AMD is trending down which is
known with its architecture Intel's
trending up and the two of those
combined in very interesting ways for
the competition between them if the
cards could play at 8K we might see this
continue to ridiculous levels shout out
of the Tomb Raider brings us back to
dx12 at 1080p high the first thing we
noticed was that the a750 had lower one
percent and 0.1 percent lows than we'd
expect for the average but they're not
low enough to a signal bad frame time
spikes or stuttering it's more of a
footnote the a770 manages to hold a
seven percent lead over the 750 making
the former again seem unworthy
especially considering cards like the
6600 can lead either the 6600s 126 FPS
average result has a 16 ahead of the
a750 a stark difference from Final
Fantasy and the 6600 XT holds a 35 lead
over the a750 we noticed that the lows
recovered in 1440p testing these results
were repeatable between multiple test
passes in both resolutions so to us this
means that the GPU might be shifting its
bottleneck more to Intel strong points
like memory performance the a750 is
about tied with the rx6600 here with a
measurable lead developing as compared
to the RTX 2060 or RTX 3050 strange
Brigade is back this one isn't played by
many people at this point but it's one
of the best optimized games we've tested
and it has Vulcan which is the real
reason we're showing it this gives a
better idea for API scaling at 1080p for
Intel house weakest situation the a750
manages 176 FPS average that has the
a770 back to its eight percent lead from
earlier and the a750 basically leads
everything else not counting 30 70s and
up so it establishes a 23 advantage over
the RTX 3060 or a massive 62 advantage
over the RX 6600 finally for 1440p the
a750 leads the 3060 by 21 and the rx6600
is led by 65 percent not much different
than before Intel just needs more games
like this so wrapping up then it's first
of all it's been a hell of a two weeks
here at GN uh we're all pretty tired
because we had the four CPUs plus we
re-benchmarks all the other CPUs because
we built new benches and test weeds then
we re-benchmarked all of the gpus all
this stuff has happened within two weeks
the it's literally thousands of test
passes at this point within two weeks
from the team here so first of all for
those of you on my team who do bother to
watch the videos after we push them out
the door thank you for getting us
through the last few weeks uh now for
the rest of you who are trying to figure
out if you want to buy this card here's
the quick recap the a770 it's about six
to eight percent better than the 750 on
average that difference is functionally
meaningless it's negligible you're
talking about a difference of sixty
dollars in actual money means a lot more
to people than a couple frames most the
time and that's what we said about the
470 the 4A the 575 the 595.80 this is a
an age to hold tale of company launches
two gpus and one of them is just
slightly better than the other one where
it doesn't really make sense to buy the
higher end one but they're probably just
trying to there's some marketing
strategy there with trying to force an
upsell in certain segments so uh that's
the good news is that it's most of a
770. now there's also staying on the
upside for a moment here if you look at
games where there's a positive light for
Arc where it's doing well which again
it's completely chaotic it's not
consistent where it does well and where
it doesn't for the average user you will
not be able to predict where it will do
well we can kind of predict it at this
point but it's mostly down to apis so
the positive side though total Warhammer
3 has the 750 at 1080p at 33 better than
the RTX 3050 and the 3050 is a little
bit more money at least at the time we
were writing this review so that's a
good thing for the 750 the 750 was also
14 better than an RTX 2060 again at
1080p now at 1440ps we've been saying
for since the A380 review it starts to
do a lot better and really pull ahead as
you increase that resolution and so for
1440 the 750 out does the 3050 by 41
that is a massive increase over even
just 1080. and it out does the 6600
non-xt by 39 percent that's in Total War
again at 1440. so that's looking good a
Rainbow Six looks really bad for the
750. so that's sort of the downswing of
this Vulcan uh has some just general
game issues right now and then Dia and
that's not Intel that's Rainbow Six
developers and then dx11 is bad for
until it's a bloodbath so in that one
the uh 2060 out did the 750 by 120
percent so useless in this game with
this API for the 750. uh F1 1080p it was
eight percent better than a 3050 a final
fantasy it was five percent better than
a 6600 a 6600 XT let it buy 11 1080p in
Final Fantasy so you know overall this
one is positioned better
the fan could probably use a little more
clearance this one's position this was
not disassembled by the way the card is
positioned better than the last one so
uh purely from performance if you only
look at this in charts and you ignore
the entirety of the software experience
and the stability and consistency in how
the product works then it starts to look
actually defensible as something to
purchase so that's good for Intel that's
where they need to be they need to be in
that the camp of like yeah I guess I can
deal with that for a little bit and hope
that they keep pushing driver updates
but for the average user we just we
still can't recommend Arc right now
because it's it's going to be
frustrating for you and we don't want
people to go out there and buy stuff
where if you're buying only on charts it
looks doable and then you're just upset
when you get home and it's not working
in a way that's easy to troubleshoot so
that's the angle to look at if you're an
Enthusiast that doesn't scare you great
consider it a couple things here so uh
first of all if you're happy with your
computer today then just general
reminder don't upgrade if you you either
upgrade because you feel like you just
want a fun project to do maybe you want
something to distract you whatever
that's great reason to upgrade but if
you're happy with the performance right
now and you don't feel like an immediate
needs upgrade go ahead and hang on to
what you have see what rolls out in the
next few months and uh you know you
stretch your dollar a lot farther that
way it's also just less waste in general
so that's a good thing we like to remind
people that because it's easy to get so
caught up in upgrading Cycles now uh
ultimately
remember also it is not the consumer's
responsibility to prop up a hundred plus
billion dollar Company by buying their
300 video cards thanks Steve so if you
genuinely need a video card right now
and you need something about this
performance and you're aware of the
downsides and you can deal with them
then
at least in terms of pure numbers it's
competitive but you shouldn't be buying
this only because you want to basically
fund Intel's Kickstarter
it owns Fabs it is one of the wealthiest
companies in the world in history it's
pretty high up there too uh you
shouldn't be buying these things purely
to support them it is not your
responsibility to pay for Intel's r d
which is what this is this is an r d
project but they had to kick it out
there into the wild because otherwise
they just can't get enough Mass exposure
to get all of those bug reports and
issues back to iterate fast enough
that's why I had to go this way so it's
up to Intel to earn your money is what
we're saying and uh it's not up to you
to to just buy it just because it's new
and that goes for any of these video
card companies but with what we have
today at least
on the positive side this one is far
stronger than the 770 was at the price
point it is a much stronger value
proposition so they're in a better place
than where they were with the 770. the
build quality is still really
disappointing uh for the card and you
can watch her tear down on that and the
drivers will keep following up as they
iterate and let you know when it gets
better and at what speed but that's it
for this one it's at least a little more
positive than the last two videos on Arc
and hopefully Intel can continue this
trend because it's getting really
interesting where it's like the best
thing that's happened to AMD is Intel
entering this Market because now AMD and
Intel a much similar market share than
Say in video which is like way out there
they can start competing with each other
in ways that should push each other
forward maybe they can start catching up
down video we have other features we
want to look at we look at xcss and at
RTX or RT and all that stuff that'll be
future pieces and we're too slammed
right now everyone here is exhausted
thanks for watching subscribe for more
go to stor.gamersaccess.net to support
our unending work on the benchmarking or
patreon.com Gamers and access if you
want to give us a few bucks thanks for
watching we'll see you all next time